This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the order of one platform platforms built a beautiful online
presence and run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more on them.
Early 17 hundreds,
the English army was not very highly thought of traditionally.
They relied on their powerful Navy to protect their islands from invasion.
And so their army wasn't nearly as experienced in the tactics of land's warfare.
If the period as the battle Hodgkin's armies of continental Europe,
but the tactics of war were changing.
The ban has said musket was replacing the pike as a standard infantry weapon.
The firepower of muskets and cannons was increasing and the concept of organized
supply chains was being refined.
So armies could be kept in the field for much longer periods of time.
No one took better advantage of these new tactics to win glory for himself and
his country than John Churchill that you have.
Marlboro Marlboro was one of the first generals to master the art of leading a
coalition army from multiple different countries and were celebrated for his
tactical genius and for his organizational skills that made his army one of the
most dangerous in Europe. He was also a natural born political animal,
rising to his heinie station in no small part due to his powerful friends,
including royalty. He would eventually be undone,
not by defeat on the battlefields,
but by political backstabbing at home brought on by his own ruthless
maneuvering, regardless of his faults,
he is still recognized today as a crucial figure in British and European history
whose actions both on and off the battlefield continue to be felt even 300
years.
[Inaudible].
John Churchill was born on may the 26th, 1650,
and his grandmother's house in Devon in Southwest England, his father.
So Winston Churchill had force on the royalist side and the recently concluded
English civil war.
There are lists that lost and King Charles had been deposed and executed the
year before.
And the victorious parliamentarians punish those who had served the broader list
cause with heavy sanctions, including fines, so steep that it forced.
So Winston's moving with his mother-in-law.
The Churchill family fortunately has turned around in 1660 when the monarchy was
restored and the Prince of Wales was crowned King Charles.
The second five years later,
John's older sister R Abella was made a maid of honor to the Duchess of York and
height. And his husband, James, the Duke of York was King Charles, his brother,
and after the Thrones of England and Scotland,
James was smitten by the 17 year old Arab Eller.
And she became his mistress and arrangement that lasted over a decade and
produced for illegitimate children as was customary for the time James rewarded
the church or family with patronage and John and his brothers were given
positions in the Royal households.
And later in the military judge who got his first taste of battle in 1672,
when England went to war against the Dutch Republic and an Alliance with France,
he served the commands of the Duke of Monmouth,
the illegitimate child of King Charles,
the second and acquitted himself well in the field.
He returned home in 1675 and soon, often at 15 year old, Sarah Jennings,
another maid of honor in the raw court. And two years later,
the two married in secret since neither of their families approved.
It's just a match.
Throughout the sixties and seventies. It became clear that King Charles,
the second would not produce a legitimate at the throne,
meanings that upon his death, the crown would go to his brother. James.
The problem was James was a devout Catholic.
There were fears that a Catholic King would try to force the country to convert
and outlaw the Anglican church.
It had been the Catholic sympathies of King Charles. The first,
that was a major factor in inciting the English civil war that had deposed him
years earlier.
What to do about the succession precipitated a crisis that dominated English
politics for over a decade King Charles supported his brother.
And so did the church or family or not Catholic themselves.
They owed their station to their friendship with James and so remains loyal to,
and even as most of parliament turned against him,
Sarah Churchill formed a friendship with James's daughter,
and that would prove to be extremely influential in the years to come while John
cultivated a friendship with James who succeeded to the throne upon the death of
his brother in 1685. Soon after James, his coronation,
the Duke of Monmouth lighter rebellion against him proclaiming himself King.
He hoped to use the fact that he was a Protestant son of King Charles,
or be it in a legitimate one to gain the throne for himself.
King James sent the Royal army under the Allah Feversham to crush the rebellion.
John Jojo was appointed second in commands and played a key role in the defeat
of the Monmouth rebellion at the battle of [inaudible] on July the sixth, 1685.
Soon though,
it became clear that Protestant fears about King James were not groundless
James' favorite Catholics and senior court positions and favorite policies that
expressed toleration for Catholics, but not for other Protestant sects,
such as Presbyterians.
He was accused of being an absolute Monarch who did whatever he wanted,
whether the people he ruled likes it or not is supported roaded steadily and
were so low that in 1688,
there was open dork of deposing him and replacing him with his daughter,
Mary and her husband, William Prince of orange,
the most powerful figure in the Dutch Republic in November 16, 88,
William landed in England at the head of a large invasion force.
James watched in horror as most of his Royal army deserted him to join the Dutch
invaders. The majority of the English population welcomed William as a savior,
both of his daughters, Mary and Anne turned against him.
But the hardest portrayal to take was that of John Churchill.
It turns out that he had been secretly plotting with William for months to
depose James and as one of James senior commanders and trusted advisors knew
what the King was planning and how to oppose it.
Churchill deserted his gang and joined Williams. Soon after he landed,
James fled the country in December and soon after William and Mary were crowned
as joint monarchs, Churchill was rewarded by being made of Marlboro,
but many people looked upon his desertion of James as a disgrace,
effectively stabbing the man who had made his career in the back just for
personal gain, more than anything. It demonstrated his ruthless ambition,
which was to help and hinder him in equal parts in the yest.
Mary never really trusted Marlboro rafter. They were crowns well after all,
if he was willing to betray one Monarch who's to say he wouldn't betray another.
If it's did to benefit him. In fact,
Marlboro maintained a secret correspondence with the depose James through the
1690s,
which is viewed more as an insurance policy in case seat was restored to the
throne.
Marlboro was not an active supporter of James or Jacobite as they were called,
but he was above all a practical man.
Marlboro made other powerful friends in this time period, such as Sydney.
Godolphin the first daughter of the treasury and Sarah who was now the favorite
of princess. And it was next in line to the throne.
Another reason the King and queen distrusted him,
although recognized as an exemplary soldier has the vanity and inability to
please as pneumonics would be as undoing in January, 1692,
it was summarily dismissed from his officers and banished from the court.
And in may,
he was accused of being a signatory to a letter that outlined a plot to replace
William with James. And he was sent to the tower of London after five weeks.
Now that it was discredited as a forgery, as Marlboro was released,
it took until 1698 for Marlboro to regain positions in the governments.
Although he still has a cool relationship with the King,
but it ends on the continents intervenes that would turn Marlboro into an
international hero. And if you want to become an international hero,
then it's time to start creating something amazing with today's sponsor
Squarespace. Now it's two simple things to remember one,
maybe you've got an idea for a website or a business, something like that,
that you want to start even a podcast, whatever. Well, two,
the only way to figure out whether that's worth doing is to get it out there
into the world. And the best way to do that is with a website.
And the best way to do a website is of course, with Squarespace,
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
You sell something online. Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
You want to do a podcast? Yes. They handle that too.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template.
You can customize to your heart's content or start from scratch or leave over an
existing domain, making everything super easy to manage.
Don't start from scratch thing. Just use a template, no excuses.
I want to see you've gone through the super easy customization process.
There's no updates. There's no patches. There's no tech BS to deal with.
And Squarespace also handles all the website stuff. Podcasts. Yes.
Mailing lists. Yes. Social integrations, of course.
Plus 24 seven support. In case you get stuck,
you go to squarespace.com for a free trial. When you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash bar graphics,
and you'll get 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain and let's
get back to it.
[Inaudible].
So politics of this period was dominated by a rivalry between the French house
of Borbon and the Austrian house of Habsburg,
the bull bonds and ruled the kingdom of France since the late 16th century and
the French King Louis the 14th was one of the most powerful and absolute
monarchs in the world. He was also known as the sun King,
not only because he took the image of the sun as a symbol,
but because he made sure that all the froms revolved around him,
perhaps bergs were an ancient family that controlled the Austrian and Hungarian
monarchies,
and also exercised control over much of Germany by essentially hereditary
control of the throne of the Holy Roman empire. Under the Bronx shift,
the Habsburgs controlled the Vos Spanish Ambar,
which while it wasn't the powerhouse that at once was still controlled as much
of the Americas, Southern Italy and the Spanish Netherlands,
which is modern day Belgium.
Most of the conflicts of this period were driven by the need to keep the balance
of power between these great two powers with the other countries of Europe
fighting each other one or the other intern in order to keep them in check.
It was a complicated and violence system.
But the only one that works in an age where monarchs were free to treat their
nations like placings, that could go to war on a whim,
a serious threat to the balance of power developed in 1700, the King of Spain,
Charles,
the second who had ruled for over 30 years was in the patchouli ill health
likely caused by genetic deficiencies resulting from centuries of inbreeding.
He was unable to produce some errands with no other close relatives to succeed
in earth,
the ball bonds and the Habsburgs competed bitterly with each other to take the
power of Spain into their own fold.
Something that would irrevocably tip the balance of power in favor of the Victor
on November, the first 1700 Charles,
the second diet as well left the throne of Spain's Phillip of Andrew,
the grandson of King to be the 14th.
The idea of the bull Barnes controlling both France and Spain was unacceptable
to Holy Roman. Emperor Leopold ended horrified the rest of Europe,
including King William.
A grounds Alliance was formed in 1701 consisting of England's,
the Dutch Republic and the Holy Roman empire to oppose Louise ambitions in
Spain. What became known as the war of Spanish succession and beginning
Third died in March,
1702 from complications that developed from a fall from his horse.
His sister-in-law was proclaimed queen Anne.
Soon after Marlboro was made captain general of all English and Scottish forces
and also made commander of deduction, high German armies as well.
He now had a huge challenge ahead of him.
He faced a French army that was considered the best in the world at the time
commands ads by Louis the 14th best marshals.
He also have to contend with an allied army with differing priorities and
squabbling factions in parliaments at home.
But it was this adversity that served to further showcase his brilliance in
commands [inaudible] commands in the low countries where the war was to be
principally forced,
immediately outmaneuvered as opponents Marshall Bufala took four cities in the
Netherlands, a grateful green mate and the Duke of Marlborough.
But when he returns to war the next year, the French foiled,
the allied designs for a quick to the war.
And as Marlboro came under attack by the politics at home Marlboro was a Tory
and they had control of the governments and had the favor of the queen.
But many of his Tory colleagues thought that a Lamb's war was a waste of time
and resources and this,
they should devote their efforts instead do deploying the Royal Navy to attack
France and Spain's overseas colonies and trade routes.
By contrast the wigs headed by a group of powerful Lord schooled.
The so were fully in support of the continental campaign and small-bore his
son-in-law was a leading wig,
but queen Anne hated the wigs and didn't want them in control of her ministry.
Marlboro was now caught between bits of political rivals and had to play a
delicate game in order to keep everyone happy,
but he could do nothing if he lost the war.
And when he returned to the field in 1704, he faced a crisis.
The main thrust of the French war effort in 1704 was against Austria.
The empire was hard-pressed by two French armies and a third commanded by
Francis ally, the electorate Bavaria,
they were advancing along the Danube river towards the Imperial capital of
Vienna. If Deanna was taken,
they would likely knock the Habsburgs out of the Warrens.
The entire Alliance would collapse. Barbara knew he needed to save the Ana,
but he also knew that the Dutch would never willingly allow him to leave their
borders and weakened the defenses of their home country.
So to get his army down the Danube,
he decided to trig both his Dutch allies and his French opponents by pretending
to March West,
then abruptly turning South and floating his army on barges down the Rhine
river, his deception worked.
He was able to match a force of 40,000 men over 250 miles in five weeks while
being completely unhindered.
This Torrid pace was accomplished with spectacular logistics plans by Marlboro
so that when his army arrived at the Danube,
it was in a fit state to fight here.
He met up with the commander of the Imperial army Prince,
Eugene of Savoy and accomplished and Flamboyan general.
He became Marlboro has great friends personally and professionally together.
They faced off against the forces of marshals to lardons Mohsin and the lecture
of Bavaria or in this time period was usually dominated by sieges,
but Marlboro taking advantage of advances in technologies, such as the socket,
bayonet sought to destroy his enemies in the field,
proclaiming that one battle is worth 10 seizures,
but the French were reluctant to find it first rating for reinforcement.
So Marlboro resolved to attack them at that position near the small village
known in English as Blenheim the allied plan was symbol.
Eugene would attack the French position on the right flank,
pinning them down at the same time. Some of Marlboro is force,
which attack the village of Blenheim,
which forms of the left flank with the two flanks pinned down Marlboro himself
would crash through the center of the line with the main body of his army,
dealing a deathly blow.
The battle of Blenheim began with the simultaneous attacks on the French flanks
at 1:00 PM.
The battle unfolded just as Marlboro had hopes the vicious and bloody flank
attacks had pinned down large numbers of French troops that were to reinforce
the center of their battle line.
More troops were pinned in the center in the hamlets of over Glau.
Now Marlboro unleashed his hammer blow a massive combined wave of cavalry,
infantry and artillery that cuts nine French battalions to pieces and sent the
center of the French line. And two panicked flight.
If a 3000 French are estimated to have drowned in the Danube during the routes,
they took thousands more prisoners,
including Marshall town off on the right to Eugene personally led an attack that
overwhelms the Bavarian artillery battery and put Marston and the Alexa to
flight. Then Marlboro turned his attention to the 10,000 soldiers.
Now tramped in the village of Blenheim finally forcing them to surrender off to
heavy fighting at 9:00 PM.
It was a stunning victory from Abra and Eugene 27,000 French would dead
wounded or captured compared with $12,000 casualties.
All of the various we're seeing overrun and it's put under Austrian military
rule knocking them out of the war and he made Marlboro the hero.
He returns to London in December,
and that's a triumphal procession to Westminster palace queen and allocated
money to build a palatial estate Blenheim palace as a reward for his deed.
It would be the high point of his career.
Yeah.
Pain of 70 and nine five was not nearly as successful for Marlboro as he was
stymied by French resistance and the reluctance of the Dutch to leave their
border defenses to attack the French.
They gave him Arbor as Tory enemies at high ammunition to cool.
Blenheim a flu cans, the land war, a waste of time. Meanwhile,
the Queen's relationship with Sarah had chilled.
Sarah was a staunch wig and campaigns tirelessly against the Tories irritating
the queen 1786 did not start any better with the French making gains in all
fronts. And the lack of allied support,
forcing Marlboro to fight in the Spanish Netherlands instead of Germany or
Italy, where he wanted to bolstered by a success Libby,
the fourteens goaded Marshall Villeroy and leaving his defensive positions in
Flanders to attack Marlboro,
seeking to avenge Blenheim and perhaps forced the Dutch out of the war Marlboro
and mess him at rental lays on may the 23rd and in a battle that took less than
four hours,
completely outmaneuvered and crushed the French inflicting 15 to 20,000
casualties compared to 3,500 of his own though, not lauded as Blenheim.
It was arguably his greatest victory of the walk strategically.
It had great implications as well as malware.
His forces captured most of the Spanish Netherlands,
including the most important cities of Brussels Antwerp.
And Bruge in 1,707. Marlboro was unable to win a victory on the battlefield,
but he achieved one diplomatically. He successfully bribed Cole Piper,
one of King, Charles,
the 12th of Sweden's chief advisors in return for Piper persuading,
Charles to launch an attack on Russia instead of interfering in the war between
the Alliance and France in 1708, he was joined in Flanders by his friend,
Prince Eugene, and together,
they won another great victory over the French that we did not.
They advanced through the Spanish Netherlands towards France itself in 1709 in
one of the bloodiest battles of the war.
They beat the French again at [inaudible],
but the affair was a bloody one and the allies suffered twice as many casualties
as the French.
It was to be the last great victory of the war for the remarkable partnership
between Marlboro and Eugene at home though,
things were turning to disaster from Arbor as chief ally and the government Nord
Godolphin had been forced to Cobell the queen to share power with the wig Shinto
permanently fracturing the relationship between the mulberries and en the queen
it's ends when you favored Abigail mash and Sarah's cousin,
and to Robert Holley,
a former ally of Marlborough who had now turned against him.
The Tories looked on the power sharing scheme as a betrayal.
And when they assumed power in 17, 10,
the wigs were swept from governments and good orphan went with them. Now,
Holly and the Tories went off to Marlborough.
They trumped up corruption charges against him that he was stealing public
money, meant for the army for his own profits.
And in December of 1711 queen Anne,
who by now had turned on Sarah completely dismissed her undefeated commander
from his post.
[Inaudible].
Members of the grands and lines with stunned by Mulberry is dismissal.
And even more shocked when it was discovered that the British government had
been hosting secret talks with the French for months beforehand,
to secure a favorable terms for themselves at the expense of everyone else.
The treaty of ULTRAX,
which ended British participation in the war was heavily slanted in favor of the
British and did little to nothing for the rest of the allies.
It kept Phillip as King of Spain in exchange for his formal renunciation of the
French throne, which maintains the balance power in Europe.
It established great Britain as the country was now cooled off to the act of
union in 1707, nudged England and Scotland into one nation.
As the dominant commercial power in the world,
some of its effects are still felt today.
The United Kingdom still controls the port of Gibraltar seeded to Britain by
Spain and the treaty of old tracks for Marlboro. However,
the peace was a bitter pill to swallow.
It had been largely responsible for British success in the world only to be
brought down by political infighting,
but really he had no one but himself to blame his attempt to play both sides to
his own benefit of back font and his inability to convince his wife, Sarah,
to be more subtle in her politicking and less haughty had alienated them both
from queen Anne Marlboro went into self-imposed exile on the continent in 1712.
It was still immensely popular in Germany and Austria and traveled extensively
over the next two years, Marlboro was to play King Maaco. One more time.
However,
queen Anne has no living heirs and as the act of settlement passed in 1701 ruled
Catholics to be ineligible to inherit the throne,
the closest Protestant relative was the elector of Hanover, George Lewis.
However, the Jacobites still hope to restore the ad to King James to the throne.
Instead it felt a Marlboro to assure a smooth transition for George.
When queen Anne died on August the first 1714 King George, the first was crowns.
The Jacobites were defeated when they Rose in rebellion and all seemed well for
the Marbury's. But in 1716,
the Duke had the first of a series of strokes that would PSAP his health and
force him to retire from public life. He watched as his enemy,
Robert Harley was stripped of his officers and briefly imprisoned and oversaw
the construction of Blenheim palace on June the 16th, 1722,
following another stroke. He died age 72.
He was given a state funeral and was buried in Westminster Abbey.
Although his remains were later removed to lie next to his wife at the chapel at
Blenheim palace, which was finished after the Duke's death.
The palace is one of the largest States in Britain,
not owned by the Royal family,
the ancestral home of the Churchill family and the Dukes of Marlboro for the
last 300 years. It was at Blenheim in 1874, that Winston Churchill was born.
This direct descendants of the Duke would go on of course,
to become the most famous prime minister in the country's history.
If you have Marlboro was one of the most inspired commanders in European
history.
He routinely outfoxed and out fought his opponents on the battlefield and his
talents for coalition building and logistics were just as important.
And its victories, his partnership with Prince Eugene,
a great general in his own right,
provided a series of stunning victories that checks the power of the sun King
and to help to facilitate Britain's rise to prominence in the 18th century,
if he had a fault,
it was his aggressive politicking and ambitions or rise to power in the first
place, though, it's hard to argue with his results once he got there after all,
not everyone wins about also thoroughly that you're given a palace named after
it. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
Don't forget to check out today's sponsor Squarespace either. And thank you.
[Inaudible].